our intern is working on editing stuff
the big clock is important big clock is
our timer tells us where we're at make
sure that we don't coach because we
could go forever and not really know
that time is moving and so we just read
over the headlines from from all the
different news sources blogs and things
like that and we just find what sticks
we get those three or four things that
we want to talk about it and it's
essential it to be something with some
sort of humorous side to it at all /
otherwise we're just talking heads and
you can get talking heads on ESPN and
that's what we like to make fun of stuff
we like to have fun with swift stuff
it's a beautiful day in the neighborhood
I'll beautiful day for our neighbor
would you be mine to the school member
so already it's christmas dude it's not
thanksgiving is Christmas let me listen
to the radio have a holly jolly
christmas are there in the base times on
here we we need to write some
thanksgiving sucks clearly three
football games this week are three great
football game um ready good audio time
what Mac your bomb nipple pics I'm
Steven Brenner I'm Jeff Ellis this
Thursday November 17 2011 this tgit
thank god it's thursday if you're gonna
have a successful podcast where you're
going to get a view of viewership to
come and listen to what you have to say
all the time there's a time commitment
that you have to you can't just record
one podcast and then wait a month and
then throw another one up there has to
be some sort of consistency and that's
what people don't understand when
they're starting out oh man if I'm going
to do this if it's a let's even if it's
just a 20-minute audio show it's 20
minutes once a week and it's not just
those 20 minutes that you're recording
there's prep time there's oxygen
production time post-production time
afterwards so it takes a real solid
commitment if you're not going to commit
to it in the beginning don't start we've
had people who started podcast and after
a third one there like it's just too
much time I can't do it anymore they
stopped to me see mean there's three
things there's there's exactly what you
talked about there has to be the level
of commitment that you're talking about
but second of all you have to be
interesting you can't just come out and
say I'm going to talk about video games
and the new assassins creed revelation
Qi yesterday and it was really cool and
I played it for nine hours last night
and shut up mom and the mom coming and
you can't do that nobody cares about you
nobody just because you can doesn't mean
you should and then the other thing is
that you actually have to have some
level of savviness with the technology
yeah with the computers with the cameras
with the audio with these RSS feed and
managing all that it's difficult yeah so
yeah he's right so not just is it a time
commitment but what do you have to say
that's gonna that people are gonna want
to come listen to I think there's a
perception that we're so big now which
isn't true but there's the perception
that we're so big now that people don't
want to bother us we have a really green
juice we do though on facebook oh yeah
we're all our our percentage of the
amount of people that act that are
active was like we make a post like tell
us about this we get a lot of people so
that's how we are getting people now to
kind of communicate with us instead of
every once in a while we'll ask for an
email like say we want to hear your
service if you're still alive and
eliminate or yeah we want to know
about that one how many people get to go
to games when they want to and be in the
press box and be in the locker rooms and
be in the press conferences and ask the
hard questions and get to do that stuff
we're going to do that it is certainly
that was kind of kept us going week we
got some unprecedented access to the
league that most fans don't have and we
get to share that with people and now
it's pretty cool you know what the fact
it's not give a damn about the NFL I
like let's see you guys talk about your
lives on what's going on in the hard
decisions you guys are having to make
and as you guys grow up and how families
change we've each what we've gone
through parceling we just have had
multiple family members died over the
last seven years and it's like just they
feel like they know us and there's an
emotional bond even though one of my
favorite things is people come up to a
sandbar I feel like I know you
it's like well you do know me I just
don't know you yeah and that's the fact
it's the truth I mean there's certain
parts of our lives so we're going to
keep to ourselves but most of our life
is just out there and so people do have
a connection to you and they feel like
they know me well that's okay um but for
people when you give them less some
people really didn't like that well the
most common that is give me a shout out
for nothing you know just just say my
sound on say my name it's like that's
pretty weird why why don't you go to
your school until you want him in the
cast if it would be okay if they put a
half-eaten reese's peanut butter cup of
jeff 8 on ebay then this entire time
that we've been doing it no one's really
been kind of negative in that way I
think our initial meeting with the NFL
back in 97 five years ago uh we went and
we met we got a chance to meet with the
with the National Football League I'm
sort of 2007 not 97 that was a long time
ago back in two thousand seven we met
with the league and they were interested
in what we're doing mostly because our
numbers are very good in the UK and so
they want to know about that
international market but they were they
didn't ultimately want to have anything
to do with this because we do take shots
at the league and it takes twice as much
as we like to have fun with the lamp on
with to me that the league it's
something it's everyone's passion and if
it's your passion you should have fun
with it too it shouldn't just be this
intensity it shouldn't just be about
winning and should also be part of it is
part of everyone's life at the deepest
levels they have football so it'll be
fun football's not going to go anywhere
and I think that what what we have we've
heard a lot of positive people that as a
matter of fact when businesses hear
about what we're doing they want to see
if they can help maybe some way um
certainly our friends are that way our
friends and family we couldn't be doing
it if our family wasn't on board but
ultimately we haven't heard anything
like what are you guys doing i think i
saw maybe one comment on youtube like
you guys need to you know get real jobs
or something like that this this this
homemade SportsCenter is not working
with one comment out of
okay so that guy has stopped watching
we've been incredibly incredibly blessed
to have so much support from our family
from our friends from our listeners and
viewers where honestly I would say it's
got to be ten thousand to one as far as
the positive to negative comments and
for that we're just so grateful because
everybody has been so supportive no one
said look dude you're 46 years old it's
about time you grew up and got a job is
what is a job in today's economy in
today's economy is about your passions
and it's about following your passions
in your dreams and hopefully being able
to pay the bills at the end of the month
yeah and fortunately right now we're
getting we're getting to do that so I
don't think we would listen to anybody
who was negative anyways we just we get
it cold stuff from from our listeners
which is just trip to Vegas two weeks
that's right Oh show dinner go out for
drinks it's like really nice he's a
doctor so yeah but it's still me it was
simple as because he couldn't anymore
put up with the hours of having a
full-time job which equaled 18 hours a
day and doing this and it was like look
this is either gonna pay money or I
gotta quit doing this all together
because it's making me crazy it's gonna
I'm gonna die well that's part of it I
mean we knew we had we knew we had
something really cool with podcast but
it had grown to a point where we needed
to take it to the next level but he's
right you know I was working the full
time job more than more than a full-time
job and then having to come and do this
late at night and we really awaited go
till well past midnight we really
weren't giving this the attention that
we felt it needed well we were playing
both worlds we're playing both sides of
the fence whereby we're kind of full
tunt we're kind of real NFL
prognosticator zand pundits and
journalist kind of wank but we're not
all land clearly because we're too
distracted and we have i knit and we
have too many other commitments i'm
fortunate i have a sugar mama i want to
say hi to my honey thank you so my
demands were much less than Stevens you
know I worked 20 hours a week and that
was okay so i made doing this totally
reasonable but for steven is ridiculous
he was working
our days and it just wasn't even
possible to try and you just come in and
you almost fall asleep in the middle of
a show because it's past midnight when
you're recording you know we're doing
our homes and our kids are telling us to
shut up and now we're you know we've got
we've got the rave cave and that's what
it's all about so we'd only we totally
thought there was time to really go all
in and that's why we're doing
we actually that we had our headsets
that's actually a much nicer cleaner
sound mm-hmm so I import the off the
video into our video power here and
start the editing process and any
process is pretty simple we match we've
got three cameras are rolling ones so
long me one so long Jeff and then the
wide and you just kind of line them all
up and then everyone sarong nope you
could tell what we were working Jeff
would go to his isolation camera to make
a point or i would go to my isolation be
able to make a point and we edit that
all in one screen and then once that is
set we then decide which images are
going to be get put on the green screen
while we're talking sometimes those are
just images of players or coaches or
play on the field today will obviously
have some fun with the mercury Morris
thing and some of those images kit and
then we use After Effects to put the
minute call me crazy I'm crazy I'll show
you crazy excited I can just actually do
it again call me crazy crazy all right
material Morris mercury Morris is at it
again about the 72 dolphins get a lunch
place of golf like bingo do something Oh
buddy cares about your 17 and 0 1972
perfect Miami donut season not because
you're wrong okay there's 22 guys you
understood i'm not every very much
there's still a lot of time and every
year they go to their favorite
convenience stores you get their bottle
of korbel champagne cheapest no better
they have some pretty awesome dog yeah i
like to get me to talk there's a corphal
and they loosen the cork and they wait
this year for the Green Bay Packers to
lose their in our heads or we're writing
the Ln we've kind of already formulated
what we kind of want to say about it but
then it's just more free-flowing it just
kind of comes out as we're doing it wait
wait your savings if you
nine passes against the New York Jets
attitude Darrelle Revis what I've been
good morning no secondary arel revisit
like by the vessel to me of all cover
corners in the NFL however you've got to
throw the ball it's only chance your ham
and who's he got out there Dan catching
the ball Mary Decker Eric Decker Decker
is going to be he's gonna be like out of
his head because his girlfriend is
performed Jessie J she's performing
poorly guys and wolves on the sidelines
during gay I know she is house Cowboy
Cheerleader brokenhearted okay all right
I like the Jets bringing this game no
way tebow has the success running the
ball for throwing the ball against this
Jesse Lohr big drama coming out of
energy because they just haven't had
enough you know what if you've been
doing it long if you know this is just
gonna be one of those days that's a
nightmare and we just you need to suck
it up not get angry and with each
other because it doesn't help you need
to be on the same side be on the same
team and just roll with it do it again
do it again do it again and the Denver
Broncos are riding a two-game winning
streak you heard me correct a two-game
winning streak wait that means the tim
tebow's actually won several games yeah
yeah Tim Tebow has one on a roll gang
here's the question for you this is a
big question o Wilton Tebow throw more
than eight passes well he's grown more
than eight passes are complete morning
as well more than a paddles are
interested so we complete should last we
yeah but if you're gonna be dis Jets
team you're going them into a passive /
me I know throw the ball to ask you I
want I know but the over/unders was on
concessions 16 passes which means to get
a complete nine and I'm being picked off
once and throw one touchdown the first
time we did it one of the cameras didn't
go so we obviously couldn't use that
shoot because every time i would go to
my isolation camera it hadn't been
recording so we had no video there
because it will look odd if i'm looking
at my eyes oh camera
we're using the wide shot so we did it
again then we started it we were almost
done and the audio crashed and we lost
the file so I had to do it a third time
then the third time we didn't check the
cameras and they were all the SD card
rom was full so in the middle of
recording they stopped recording because
of the cash card triples so you just
kind of like reset the whole thing then
the fourth thing the four time we did it
everything was fine but buddy over there
had forgot to hit record on the audio so
we had no people so i took the fifth
time to get it all done that was just a
bad day
this is going to be run so he's telling
guys his corners the wide receivers
going to do a post around here he's
gonna do a curl here call me crazy crazy
look at some point at some point you
have to be as a coaching staff
knowledgeable enough to say there's
somebody on that staff on that sideline
who knows what we might be calling let's
change it up I read possibly I reblogged
about to Regis novels so
complain all the saints worksheet and is
that night pattern Oh Steve
this buffet from the keyboard
you know the bathroom
very cool
yeah I I think the biggest thing is to
do your best to know your audience as
well as you can there's there's two
sides there's no your audience as best
you can and try and tailor some of your
content for them but also be really
selfish about what you know is funny
what you know is clever what you know is
original and don't deviate from that
because the more you if you over tailor
your stuff for your audience then you're
watering down what's pure about who you
are and what you have to say and so I
like to think about people that I know
that that I know this joke will make
them laugh or something like that but
the same time some of my most biggest
passionate things I don't care what
anybody thinks about it and I think
that's usually when people are most
riveted my daughter is probably one his
most apt to try and follow in my
footsteps for no other issue tonight
completely but she is an artist and she
is the creative type and she spends her
time with her phone making movies and
things and sharing them with her friends
and making very creative images and
stuff so she's probably the one who's
most have to follow and what I encourage
her as long as you're able to eat at the
end of the day and as long as you're
able to have a roof over your head in a
semi safe neighborhood you should
absolutely do everything you can to
follow your dreams period full stop but
that was a dark chocolate reeses it just
be in all fairness that was a special
happy Teresa's one of our UK listeners
family did he give you the